[Musica]
siete a cena una di quelle cene dove non
conoscete quasi nessuno siete In quella
fase della cena dove con lo sguardo
cercate la persona che potrebbe salvarvi
portando con sé il vino a tavola ma una
volta
inquadrata prima che possiate tirare un
sospiro di sollievo vi accorgete che
anche lei in questo caso lui Gino vi sta
fissando in quell'istante a malincuore
capite che oltre a rivestire il ruolo di
uomo vino sarà anche colui che non vi
farà una domanda qualsiasi Ma la domanda
Quella scomoda e con scomoda intendo
proprio che vi sta stretta che quando vi
arriva vi vi verrebbe di
slacciarsi
ariri la voce se davanti a voi c'è un
pubblico è quella domanda che il più
delle volte tocca un argomento a voi
caro e sentite stretta perché vi risulta
difficile ricavarvi Lo spazio ed il
tempo per muovervi in quella domanda e
soprattutto trovare una risposta che sia
per voi quella giusta
ma torniamo a cena a lui Gino che mentre
si avvicina a rallentatore tenendo con
sé in ostaggio il vino si ferma davanti
a me inspira e a gran voce mi chiede e
tu Azzurra che lavoro
fai senza aver bisogno di guardarmi
attorno sento tutti gli occhi dei
presenti puntati addosso ma questa volta
anziché rispondere in modo sbrigativo o
parlare troppo velocemente per paura di
annoiare chi mi ascolta mi dico Ok Azzu
è la tua
occasione metto seduto il buon Gino
vicino a me mi alzo e a tutti dico se
avete pazienza 15 minuti vi accompagno a
fare un giro in ciò che faccio per
lavoro premessa ho la gran fortuna che
il mistiere che pratico da 18 anni a
questa parte sia anche la mia grande
passione un compagno di vita in grado di
stupirmi ed emozionarmi giorno dopo
giorno Se volessimo intanto appoggiare
una parola sul tavolo potremmo dire che
faccio l'artigiana e Sarebbe corretto
fino ad un certo punto perché oltre a
dare forma alla materia che ho sotto le
mani in modo unico ed irripetibile entro
in relazione con un materiale che di
materiale in realtà ha ben poco che è
quo
umano e posso garantire che è un tessuto
talmente delicato prezioso e intricato
che L'unico strumento col quale può
essere maneggiato bene è il
cuore è un lavoro che appunto è manuale
creativo che si sviluppa in un ambito
sociale culturale e artistico ma anche
psicologico emotivo ed
estetico è un lavoro che esiste da
sempre e che per sempre es
perché è inarrestabile segue il suo
corso come un fiore che cresce o una
foglia che cade non puoi controllarlo è
la
natura è un lavoro Grazie al quale
spontaneamente nasce musica Perl più di
quel jetz dal ritmo sincopato scandito
da battute dispari con la persona che ho
davanti lame di forbice che tagliano il
tempo ed un sottofondo Vatt Ventoso che
rievoca i primi suoni che ci hanno
raggiunto così
dicono bene A questo punto il Gino in
preda alla sete e con un crampo alla
mano potrebbe interrompermi con un bel
Vabbè Azzu Ma fai i
capelli ora se Tralasciamo il fatto che
sul fa i capelli l'immagine che mi
appare davanti è quella di una me
novantenne che sferruzzo all'impazzata
fabbrica capelli per tutto il quartiere
e ci concentriamo invece su su verbo
fare cioè realizzare produrre
concretamente a questo punto del tour ma
solo per ora potremmo dare per buono che
sì faccio i
capelli allora però cosa significa fare
i capelli ad una
persona da piccoli o con i vostri bimbi
avete mai giocato al gioco della
parrucchiera per giocare alla
parrucchiera si ha bisogno di di uno una
vittima che potrebbe essere una bambola
un'amica un parente stretto o anche voi
stessi due colori e qualsiasi tipo d'
aggeggio presente in casa purché possa
fungere da decoro per la vostra opera
tre le forbici qu la grande protagonista
del gioco la
fantasia unendo questi quattro punti vi
most ò Come tagliare colorare o
acconciare i capelli sia una ricerca
verso qualcosa di molto più profondo
dell'apparire o del ricalcare le
mode prendiamo Marianna una delle donne
della mia vita ma anche
cliente qualche tempo fa in uno dei suoi
classici periodi allamari dove la
situazione più semplice da gestire
potrebbe essere un trasloco Regno Unito
Italia con i tre figli al seguito due
dei quali gemelli mentre sta conseguendo
l'ennesimo Master e se ha fame cucina
contemporaneamente un uovo alla cocco
uno in camicia e uno fritto mi chiama e
Fissa un appuntamento con me in
salone durante la nostra chiacchierata
pretaglio che per fortuna non ha mai
ascoltato nessuno Fino ad oggi le chiedo
Mari ma se tu avessi una bacchetta
magica che capelli vorresti
Azzu io li vorrei lunghi e corti
tipo ma lunghi non come stanno adesso
schiacciati dritti tristi ma più da
insegnante di surf che nel tempo libero
pratica yoga e poi mangia avocado e
corti perché così quando entro in studio
o supervisiono qualche colloquio mando
avanti quella Forte decisa sicura di sé
un po' la Miranda del diavolo veste
Prada ed è uscita da lì quel giorno
magari non con il taglio dell'anno ma
sicuramente con quello di cui aveva
bisogno in quel
momento perché il punto è
che
[Applauso]
Scusate tagliare colorare o acconciare i
capelli ci consente di essere chi
vogliamo
a seconda delle occasioni che la vita ci
presenta con quei capelli addosso
cambiamo postura atteggiamento stile ci
muoviamo in modo diverso li muoviamo in
modo diverso li sentiamo più nostri
diventano quell'accessorio amico dal
quale non ti separi mai non puoi ce
l'hai sempre lì a portata di mano a
ricordarti chi sei Ti riconnetto a te
con un semplice gesto
uno di quei gesti che ti fanno stare
bene perché quando prenotiamo un
appuntamento da quella che fa i capelli
è per trovare qualcuno che riesca a
tradurre in immagine ciò che abbiamo
dentro per sentirci attraenti per ciò
che siamo non per ciò che non siamo ed
esprimerlo attraverso un linguaggio che
in silenzio parla di noi al
mondo abbiamo tutti bisogno di vedere
proiettata vecchio una diapositiva di
noi che sia Ego sintonica che sia cioè
coerente con chi siamo o siamo stati noi
fino a quel momento storico Ma che
giocando con i capelli stuzzichi
curiosità verso noi stessi e che questa
curiosità ci porti a scoprire tanti
ospiti che abitano dentro al nostro
condominio
emotivo dandoci così la possibilità di
far nascere una relazione più intima con
noi stessi stessi e coi nostri cari
Alterego Guardate queste
immagini stessa
persona capelli diversi Vi verrà
spontaneo pensare le stanno meglio così
le stanno meglio cosà e questa è la
parte
razionale ora per le ultime due foto vi
chiedo di sperimentare un altro modo e
non
Barate chiudete gli
occhi a
apriteli chiudete gli
occhi
apriteli avete notato come se per un
attimo Spegnete il cervello il cuore
manda avanti le
sensazioni perché un volto non è la
somma dei lineamenti un volto è fatto di
espressioni ed è l'espressione a farci
percepire bella una persona non è la
simmetria i denti bianchi o la pelle
levigata a farci provare quel sorriso
interno anche doloroso Quando
incontriamo qualcuno o qualcosa di bello
davanti a noi Anzi è proprio grazie alle
sue
imperfezioni ai più piccoli dettagli di
cui è composta e ai misteri che questi
Celano che si crea quella tensione verso
un algoritmo che non serve capire
studiare o risolvere per che la bellezza
quella vera non è misurabile va
vissuta Esiste un termine che forse può
esprimere meglio ciò che intendo che è
radioso ovvero luminoso fulgido
raggiante Infatti se ci pensate spesso
si utilizza per descrivere l'aspetto
morbido e arrotondato di una donna
incinta il sorriso scolpito di rughe di
una anziano o gli occhi affamati di vita
di un bambino sdentato che scopre il
mondo per la prima volta e se tra i
tanti voi che ci sono dentro di voi
avete custodito quella parte fanciulla
ludica
disinteressata è molto probabile
probabile che riuscirete a vivere
appieno l'esperienza della bellezza di
cui vi sto
parlando a riconoscere la persona dentro
lo specchio come la più bella del mondo
e a trattarla con cura e con
gentilezza c'è un esercizio che Vi
suggerisco e arriva direttamente da una
donna
bellissima la quale sosteneva che
sentire è il verbo delle
emozioni diceva ci si sdraia sulla
schiena del mondo e si sente
provateci Allora concedetevi di sentirla
la bellezza sentirete anche una gran
stretta al cuore Questo è certo ma ne
varrà Comunque la pena e poi se proprio
non ce la fate c'è sempre quella che fa
i capelli a correre in vostro aiuto a
tal proposito
Gino ancora lì imperterrito con la sua
bottiglia di vino ormai calda i
commensali affamati che aspetta una
risposta quindi per concludere e svelare
così l'arcano mistero Ruberò le parole
di un mio piccolo grande amico
Franci che oggi ha 6 anni ma che una
risposta alla domanda è tu Azzurra che
lavoro fai ce l'ha sempre avuta dato che
la prima volta che ha sentito il tocco
delle mie mani ed il suono delle mie
forbici era dentro la pancia della sua
mamma La leggenda narra che 3 anni fa in
un lontano paesino della Scozia la nonna
all'insaputa della madre amica della
sottoscritta lo porta a tagliarsi i
capelli da
un'altra il fedele Franci in preda laa
disperazione ma con decisione dichiara
voglio zia Azzu la malcapitata collega
sospettiamo cugina di terzo grado del
nostro Gino gli chiede E chi sarebbe
questa Azzu Cosa fa e lui le risponde
zia Azzu è un'esperta della Bellezza
perché perché zia Azzu fa belle le
persone
[Applauso]
Grazie